to people who currently live together
are about to attend church have a party
go on a short holiday then carry on
living together what's big about that
hey youtubers is Charlie and quite
possibly the greatest episode of
Sherlock ever just aired so this is
going to be my review since a lot of you
might not have seen it yet I'll try and
keep out as many spoilers as possible
I'll also be taking questions for my Q&A
video tomorrow be sure to subscribe to
get it if there's any questions you have
specifically about sine of three just
post them in the comments and I'll
include in my Q&A video and just like
this weekend I'll post my breakdown
video a couple days after I post that
Q&A video just like my last review I'm
gonna do my top 5 moments and then I'll
do my review so we got to keep this stag
party on schedule so let's get started
number 5 the editing in the story
normally I talk about specific parts of
the story but there was this incredible
way the story was told in several
different scenes even when Sherlock
wasn't in his mind palace I loved how
Sherlock essentially shows you the end
result first and then rewinds to show
you how everyone got there like learning
how Sherlock became Watson's best man
while he was in the middle of his
wedding speech they've done mechanical
things like this with the story for a
long time but something about this
episode in the bright colors of the
wedding juxtaposed with the drab colors
of Baker Street just made it feel like
you were jumping down the rabbit hole of
Sherlock's past the whole time the joke
is all in Sherlock and it's so much fun
they made fun of him on the show in the
past but in this episode it's like
Sherlock walking right into a face full
of pie and it was amazing number 4
Sherlock stag party watching the writers
explained to us what Sherlock and Watson
would do at a stag party was amazing
it's a fair question what would those
two do if one of them had a stag party
the general decline of the evening into
what ended is the funniest case they've
ever attempted with just brilliant
I am totally inviting drunk Sherlock to
my stag party and we're gonna solve the
out of some cases number 3
Sherlock's wedding speech
it's a wedding episode and of course
Sherlock was always going to be the best
man so there was always going to be a
sherlock wedding speech but first
watching a side character get her own
montage was so much fun and to the
comedy of Sherlock's actual speech was
so much funnier when it got tied up with
the 'greater murder mystery of the
episode it was like having a
conversation with someone while they're
flipping channels on the television just
constantly jumping from story to story
in time and space or in time and you
know Sherlock's my space
number two mind Palace internet chat
room so let's not try to spoil this too
much for people who haven't seen it yet
because a very notable character makes
an appearance
inside the mind Palace but just from a
production standpoint seeing the camera
jump back and forth between the real
world and this really big set that
looked just like an orchestra pit was so
clever it was almost like Sherlock was
conducting a symphony in his mind while
carrying on this conversation with all
these chatroom women I was also really
impressed at how they visualized
Sherlock imagining each woman changing
in real time as a result of the answers
that they gave him in this chat room of
all the scenes that they filmed in this
episode I have a feeling the mind palace
scene took them the longest to film just
because there were so many characters
and so many different bits of dialogue
that were combined and my number one
thing about the episode soul man
Sherlock so without going into the plot
or the more specific details of the
episode a lot of people's complaints
about Sherlock being a dick in episode 1
are largely answered in this episode we
actually learn a couple of new things
about his personality and they place
them in this much much warmer context as
a character if Mycroft is the barometer
for coldness then Sherlock just became
so much more precious to the fandom just
to give you an idea
tumblr exploded after this episode much
more so than any other episode of
Sherlock previously overall this episode
was actually my favorite episode so far
but just to give you an idea how I play
series 3 in the greater context of the
show so far each new episode has been my
new favorite I don't think that episode
3 will be able to match the you know
preciousness of this episode but there
is a good chance that it could be an
even better episode they've done such an
amazing job this season so it's no
surprise that this episode was a home
run for the fandom as I mentioned
earlier the way the story was told was
so much more fun jumping around in time
and space so much mostly because the
filming locations just looks so distinct
the way they used music with some of the
visuals was also very creative I don't
want to spoil it too much but there are
a couple scenes where the Sherlock theme
plays to some very great comedy there's
even some dubstep sequences to put
things into context the stag party in
the wedding could have just been used to
have a lot of fun but each moment was
really true to the characters and in
service of this larger murder mystery
storyline the episode even helped me on
a practical level I just found out which
game I'm going to play the next time I
have a party gets below in the comments
what I'm
talking about also be sure to let me
know what your favorite moment was I
know almost every single moment was a
favorite moment but try to pick your
most favorite and don't forget I'm
taking questions for that Q&A video
write them in the comments right now
click here for my breakdown of episode 1
empty hearse and click here for my
review that episode thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives